a un paso de la basílica de san marcos
de venecia se encuentra un edificio que
suele pasar desapercibido
la procuraduría antigua hasta finales
del siglo 18 el edificio estaba ocupado
por los procuradores de la ciudad que
vivían y trabajaban aquí eran la élite
de la república de venecia por kurt
actor ya los procuradores eran
funcionarios municipales muy importantes
que supervisaban la gestión de la ciudad
las finanzas de sus habitantes pero
también asuntos sociales como el cuidado
de los huérfanos y las viudas el
edificio está abierto al público por
primera vez en 500 años y los primeros
visitantes están entusiasmados
es maravilloso siempre admirado este
edificio desde la plaza sin poder entrar
hoy por fin podemos descubrir el
interior sensacional
estamos impacientes por verlo es
extraordinario han hecho un trabajo de
restructuración fantástico michael peat
otan cheese me sorprende que hayan
conseguido crear un espacio tan moderno
en un edificio tan histórico es precioso
es una mezcla perfecta de lo antiguo y
lo nuevo gran tipo de moda en el
interior repartidos en 12.000 metros
cuadrados hay oficinas espacios de
exposición y salas como está aquí los
frescos de las paredes han sido
completamente restaurados pues está
presente o mira aquí en esta pequeña
zona puedes ver que hemos trabajado para
recrear la homogeneidad en la superficie
arriba homogeneidad respecto al contexto
alberto trabajo en el proyecto de
restauración estuvo aquí cuando
retiraron algunos revestimientos de las
paredes y encontró estos frescos
originales y
de repente encontramos esta imagen
delante de nosotros con una hermosa
sorpresa un momento emotivo nos sentimos
muy afortunados podemos ver un paisaje
típico veneciano con barcos y la laguna
mientras en el interior los visitantes
también pueden disfrutar de unas vistas
excepcionales a un lado del edificio
está la plaza de san marcos y al otro
los característicos canales de esta
ciudad patrimonio mundial de la unesco